[Music]
and we begin this Christmas Eve morning
with growing threats to US National
Security and the biggest unknown coming
from the wideopen southern border with
the current unprecedented surge of
illegal migrants now averaging 10,000
people a day from more than 150
countries Crossing into America
illegally every day Customs and Border
Protection source is telling Fox News
that for the fiscal year which began on
October 1st more than 698,000 people
have been encountered at the Southern
border with more than
214,000 illegally crossing for the first
21 days of this month alone the border
patrol has released more than 386,000
migrants into the country with notices
to appear in court those court dates by
the way are often 7 to 10 years later
they are asked to come back in 2031
nearly 79,000 Goda aways since October
alone these numbers of course do not
account for the untold number of people
who have evaded detection altogether and
have disappeared into the country
without a trace of who they are or what
their intentions are the Border crisis
has been ongoing since day one of the
Biden Administration when Biden
overturned the Trump era border policies
now the President says he is sending his
top officials to Mexico including
Secretary of State Anthony blinkin and
Homeland Security secretary Alejandra
mayorcas they'll travel in the coming
days to Mexico to meet with president
oor to discuss quote border challenges
unquote here's house Homeland Security
chairman mark GRE with me here last
weekend on his committee's hearing with
FBI director Christopher Ray on the
number of people apprehended at the
border who were actually on the US's
terrorist watch
list I had director Ray in front of my
committee for our worldwide threats
briefing and he clearly said you know
that the open border has created both an
increased risk for his agents who are
now hunting these individuals inside the
United States and certainly an increased
risk to to the American people and he's
honestly he expressed a real fear and
worry about what what's happening in
inside our country 294 terrorist watch
list folks since this president came to
office compare that to only 11 during
the entire Trump
Administration uh wow big numb joining
me right now in this Sunday morning
Futures exclusive is Wisconsin Senator
Ron Johnson who sits on the Senate
Homeland Security committee Senator good
to see you this morning Merry Christmas
to
you good morning a Merry Christmas to
you well you've said that this is by far
the most important issue this country
faces today tell us
why well it is a clear and present
danger to America it's obvious I mean
we're getting numb to the numbers you
laid out the case quite well in your
opening but six million people since the
start of the bid Administration have
come into this country illegally and we
don't know where they are 1.7 are what
they call known Goda ways that's a
misnomer because we detected them but we
have no idea who they are we don't know
where they are either and this is
impacting people that in in a largely
unseen fashion uh I I want to really ask
your listeners to consider let's say
you're Customs border patrol agent on
the border and you're having to deal
with like on Monday
14,591 day occurrence that's occurring
day after day after day 24/7 it never
stops and so this is completely out of
control you have a Administration
unfortunately that just calls it a
challenge you know the challenge we have
in dealing with this Administration is
they cause the problem they are the root
cause they want an open border so I
appreciate the fact that they're going
down to Mexico to maybe try and do
something about this but that's like
three years too late again the the horse
is already out of the barn here the the
implication this has for large and small
communities you you hear mayor Adams in
New York state it's going to destroy a
city 100,000 migrants that's less than
2% of the 6 million in small towns for
example one in Wisconsin a town of
15,000 they had over 400 children in
their school system that are migrant
they don't speak even the same dialect
as Spanish so they have to hire
additional interpreters it's
overwhelming law enforcement that also
can't understand these individuals when
they're making calls so this is under
the surface it's unseen it's unreported
the repercussions of this massive
unprecedented flow are going to be with
us for years probably decades this is a
disaster well I don't understand why the
administration does not see this as an
urgency and a threat to National
Security why do you think that
is well right now the only thing they
see is a threat to Joe Biden's
re-election which is why they're stying
to do something about it you know the
other point I need to make here Maria
this is so
unprecedented this is going to take
unprecedented actions to fix it uh the
same old business as usual let's do a
deal you know let's let's tweak the the
legislative language it's not going to
work when you have Customs and Border
Patrol and law enforcement so
overwhelmed by this process you know CH
change of legisl legislative language
isn't going to work we need to stop this
flow we we need to show the world that
we are going to secure our border we're
going to seal it we have to do that uh
because as long as there's a chance of
being able to come in here people will
still come and again
1459 people in one day alone and that's
an during an average of 10 11,000 a day
uh it's it's just overwhelming the
system it's just incredible Senator it
really is and I guess there's a
population out there who want this they
want a new world order they want to
fundamentally change
America yeah they want Global governance
they want no borders uh they certainly
want people come into this country and
probably destroy it uh so that I guess
we level the playing field the rest of
the world so no this this is going to
destroy our country there's there's no
other way of looking at this and again
I'm not Zen xenophobic I'm not racist I
actually want a robust legal immigration
system so people coming into this
country can work and they can do it in
the the above ground economy not the
underground economy not be exploited by
the human traffickers the sex
traffickers look at the drug overdoses
being caused by this so Biden's open
border policy is is facilitating the
multi-billion Dollar business model some
of the most evil people on the planet
and that threatens our homeland National
Security well you know we we spoke also
with Cardinal Dolan about this and you
know he was very clear about immigration
he says look the church wants a safe and
secure border we're going to run some of
his comments next weekend on this
wideopen border because they were quite
telling uh what the Cardinal feels but I
want to get your take on what we're
giving the the illegals that are coming
in there are lots of reporting out there
that we issue them cell phones um in
addition obviously to food stamps and
and housing but why are we giving them
cell
phones and do you know that to be true
have to ask I I think that is true you
know obviously we're paying for their
planes and and plane and bus rides all
over this country we don't keep track of
where they are um again is that the
point of giving a cell phone is that the
point of giving a cell phone to track
where they are that's what I'm
asking why give them a cell that I think
I think many of them already have cell
phones and that's one of the things
that's increasing the flow here as well
once again this country and by the way
cbp's goal last time I was down the at
the border was to process and disperse
in 8 hours and other words encounter
them process and disperse to All Points
of America but once they have those cell
phones if they brought them in or
they're given them they start calling
down to their family members and just
more and more people come because that's
reality no matter what this
Administration says that oh we've got
control of the Border people know they
don't they they know that if they get
into America they're going to be able to
stay here because their court dates are
7 8 10 years out in the future it it's
it's deao amnesty that's what the policy
of this Administration is so how can
Republicans do a deal with this
Administration and their Democrat allies
in the Senate that want the open border
that caused this that's a real conundrum
so is that why basically the Republicans
left town and did not do a deal in terms
of uh policy change at the border uh as
a as a reason to send money to Ukraine
where does that stand I know when you
all come back and January we've got
plenty of of dates uh deadlines January
19th the government runs out of money uh
February 2nd Government funding also
Runs Out Of Money March 8th FAA
Authority April 19th fisa April 30th
potential cut across the board sequestra
to disc discretionary spending what's
the priority when you guys come
back well you know from a standpoint of
Senate leadership on both sides of the
aisle that they've gotten this habit
this well- home process of jamming us at
the end of the year whether it's a
massive Omnibus spending bill in this
case they wanted to do the supplemental
and attach to with some modest
immigration reform and some of us said
we're not playing that game anymore
speaker Johnson said no we're going to
do a CR get s next year so we're not
jammed before Christmas and a bunch of
us just did not come back last week when
Chuck Schumer wanted to work with leader
McConnell and pass a supplemental bill
for Ukraine that had some kind of
negotiated settlement on the border it's
just wasn't going to work so we said no
we're not playing that game and
fortunately we forestalled that but yeah
we'll be facing that we get back in
January so are these the issues that
gets the GOP elected in 2024 is it the
border is it the inaptitude on economic
policy how do you change the situation
and how do you get different leadership
in place in
Washington I hope the American public is
paying attention the the look at
Democrat governance the Biden
Administration their game game plan of
open borders 40 40-year High inflation
massive deficit spending a waren fossil
fuel the embarrassing and dangerous
surrender in Afghanistan that emboldened
people like Putin to invade Ukraine
emboldened diatas and Hamas so Democrat
governance is a disaster for this
country I hope American Americans have
their eyes open to that fact
unfortunately we have a media that's a a
cheerleader for the the Democrat and the
liberal the radical left agenda so it's
a real problem well at the same time
you've got election interference
underway we're going to get into this
with John Ratcliffe coming up but the
Colorado Supreme Court uh decis is out
there in terms of removing Trump's name
from the ballot final word
there well radical leftism has
infiltrated every institution of this
country our courts our education system
uh government agencies it's it's a real
problem uh that's what needs to be
rooted out radical leftism are you going
to do anything about it you going to
stand up to Mitch McConnell on these
issues well I have been I led the effort
to make sure that we delayed the the
vote on any kind of supplemental and
border of security Packers so we get
back in January so we're we're doing
what we can but we need the public
support all right Senator we'll be
watching have a very merry Christmas we
so appreciate your time this morning hi
everyone I'm Brian kilme I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now